having a defense available to
householders defending themselves
but not to women in abusive
relationships
defending themselves against someone
they know can be dangerous and violent
towards them
is discriminatory and in the week that
the woman sarah everard
was abducted and we suppose killed
because remains have been found in a
woodland in kent
i would argue that at the next
opportunity for any bill that's
appropriate
i might actually put in an amendment to
create a curfew for men
on the streets after 6 pm which i feel
would make women a lot safer
and discrimination of all kinds would be
lessened
discrimination of all kind would be
lessened by discriminating the
instrument
you said green party and i went yeah
mainly
you know
i don't um
okay all right let me let me let me
switch it up
all right then let me switch it up
you imagine if we went to
you imagine if we went to chicago we
said we're putting in a curfew for black
folks
no but yeah shouldn't that wasn't that
we were supposed to do yeah because
there's a predominantly
high levels of crime in some parts of a
city
no black folks okay
uh
do i need to say anything
i don't think you've that's when the
video that we don't need you know what
this going we're going to switch it up
y'all do the commentary
cause this is beyond me
this as this is beyond
me you know what y'all do the commentary
y'all comment it up y'all
y'all respond so just to give you guys a
bit of context
this was filled because of the fact that
somebody ended up disappearing and they
believed to have been
you know all right now uh in response
there's a lot of uh they're playing
sure they're they're planning a vigil
for the uh the
the woman who who's gone and a lot of
people in recounting their experience
and this was the
uh response from i believe her name is
jenny jones from the green party
um you know what hold up let me let me
play devil's advocate wow
let me play devil's advocate go ahead
maybe maybe this is performative
and because the fact that we have a
curfew in place to protect women
or and men from the coronavirus by not
letting people to move around and you
know
do all this she's basically saying well
we're willing to do this much to protect
everyone from this pandemic or whatever
maybe we should put in a curfew for men
because they're the ones endangered
women and that's like the leap that she
was trying to make
if i'm trying to be generous well
i i'd like to believe she's not potato
enough who's the danger
am i being too generous yeah hold on in
in the corona virus
who's the danger hold on anybody anybody
so they will did a curfew on the people
that was endangered
by that logic it would be the woman that
would have to have a curfew
i mean look i'm assuming this is
performative it was very weird comments
if she is being serious i don't know
what to tell you
um you know we also have to get out of
this idea that like most men are out
there hurting or harming people
and if you were to alienate and take the
rights of of a huge chunk of people
based off of the actions of a minority
and if you start to overrepresent this
problem as if like all men are engaged
in this behavior
then you're gonna leave yourself in a
place where you're gonna be making bad
legislations on bad ideas
so we just have to be careful about the
perception that we put out there in
regards to this issue but
that's my thoughts the thing is this all
right yeah
go ahead tell them
it's not solving the issue it's
camouflaging it with something else
and you're gonna have serial killers and
you're gonna have people that are gonna
be there
they're still gonna do those deeds
but camouflaged or they're going to find
a way to
yeah how long let's say the let's say
this [ __ ] was was put in place
how much longer do you think women are
going to keep going to clubs before they
give up on it all together
no it's dead because the whole club
scene revolves about around
men buying things yes there's some women
buying things you got your money and
that's great but
yeah pubs bars yeah taverns yeah yeah
revolve on that but yeah put the curfew
put it in put put the curfew put it in
put it in put it in put the curfew put
it in with all the meat 6 p.m
all the man in i hope it happens you
know what i hope it happens i want to
see how fast society crumbles
that's then men quit their jobs so they
can go out during the day yeah
right then at night time they stay in so
you ain't get no booty cause ladies have
to work
right you're not gonna see nothing
you're not gonna get no unless it's your
living husband
whoo i would love to see this happen i
would love to see this happen and this
is actually what
would i what i've said when you know do
it do it when trump do it
do it do i want to see that do it you
pro
you know sometimes because sometimes
when something's really dumb you're like
you know what
do it do it
because if i even have to explain this
just do it just do it do it nike
just do it put all the man inside at six
you know what
[ __ ] it five yeah yeah
and you get a perm perfect you get a you
got a permission
to go to work so what you think those
people that are hurting women
are going to do no what no no no no no
no hey
do it do it can't wait men men who waste
less time going out and trying to see
people
or being on the streets after hours are
probably going to stay in and find
better ways to be productive
uh so you know what i hope it happens i
think it might be good for everybody
that's my fault yeah just do it i want
to see that change i want to see it
do it now do it now some people nev like
they don't think about
the repercussions they really think
about a problem this is what it is
but it's bigger than that there's more
things that are involved in that but no
no do it [ __ ] do it i want to see it
i'm all for it
it's gonna be in the uk though
foreign